>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Margaret Barker:
Good morning.
I have to tell you,
I'm just amazed
that my little organization in
Albuquerque, New Mexico is here
in Washington, D.C. with
these wonderful people.
Let me tell you a little
bit about Reading Works
and what our program is.
We are one of the thousands
of community-based
Adult Literacy programs
across America and Canada.
We have two employees,
and we have 59 volunteers,
and we serve 200 people a year.
Our program, like a lot
of community-based literacy
programs for adults was --
we were focused on a
goal-oriented curriculum.
Which meant if a client
comes in and says,
"I need to get a driver's
license", we ask our tutors
to figure out how
that could happen.
And we discovered that
it wasn't working.
Our population, 60 -- no,
let me get this right,
86% of our students
raging from age 19 to 82,
read below the age --
the fifth grade level.
And the majority of those
read at third grade level.
We also teach English the
second language to immigrants.
Of those students,
almost all of them came
in not speaking English at
all, or speaking English
at a very limited level.
So, we discovered this goal
oriented tutoring isn't going
to work for these people.
So, what did we do about it?
We spent about a year
and a half looking
at what worked, what
didn't work.
Doing research, trying to
find books already written
that we could use, and
we didn't find any.
So, we created our
own curriculum,
and it's called 12
Weeks to Reading.
It's based on phonemic
and alphabetic awareness.
It can be used for English
the Second Language learners,
it can be used for
reading students.
It's designed to be able to
be taught by someone who reads
at a seventh or eighth
grade level.
The advantage of that is
any program can use it.
Right now, we are communicating
with the Drug Court
in our community where
probationers can not only come
as students, but can come as
tutors and come as teachers.
And they can use this
curriculum for peer tutoring
to teach people phonemic
and alphabetic awareness.
It works in three
months, and it works .
Of our current -- first cohort
that we practiced it on,
100% of the people
increased their skill levels
within that three months.
It is beyond our dreams of what
it would do for our students.
Right now, I'm tutoring
a man who's 62 years old,
came in reading in the
program at second grade level.
We're about a quarter of the
way through the curriculum,
and for the first time
in his life he's reading.
It -- I can't tell you what this
means to people, it is, well,
literacy work, and
we all know this,
is about the dignity
of the individual.
Whatever people are doing
in Vietnam, in Afghanistan,
in Alaska, it's all designed
to give people dignity,
and to give them
control over their lives.
So, in Reading Works
when we have for example,
a 64 year old Navajo
gentleman who went to school
for six months in his life.
At four months of our
program, he's writing poetry
that we're publishing
in a newspaper.
These kind of results means
so much to individuals,
and then it passes
down to their children.
And I can't tell you how
honored we are to be here today.
Thank you so much.
We brought the curriculum with
us, Cindy Ketchum is here,
she's our program coordinator,
one of our two employees.
And if anyone wants to look at
it, we'll gladly show it to you,
and show it how works,
because it is,
I have to say, absolutely
brilliant.
So, thank you again, and we
are so honored to be here.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.